what did you think of the one piece live
action oh I've seen like bits like you
cannot avoid on social media you seen
the bits but I haven't like watched
through the entire scene but I'm glad
that it's being popular but I feel like
the point of having liveaction adapation
is just to bring more nomies to like
anime and that's pretty much what it's
done you know that's pretty much what
the one piece live action has done
totally that every other live action has
failed at it doesn't really need to
pleas fans but it's great if you can
well it's gotten so many people who had
maybe heard about one piece but never
had the courage to like start the manga
or start the anime to actually be like
oh let me just like take a little like
quick taste test of this and then I I
have a lot of my friends and and you
know G and I'm sure Conor does as well
where like never well yeah but like
never never had any interest in watching
anime or reading mang or anything who
watched the live action one piece and
was like I might give it a go now oh
cool you know so I think that's I think
that's a pretty successful live action
if it does the opposite effect like say
Dragon Ball live action or attack on
Titan live action or of those then it's
like I think you've just kind of failed
as a wish there was somewhere I could
like kind of Show anime people and be
like and hide all the weird [__] in the
closet for like 5 Seconds watch watch
DEATH don't worry about the horse Idol
anime don't worry about don't don't ask
about that hey man the horse Idol anime
was like entry level stuff
um which is really which is actually
really well
animated good
show yeah in terms of the idol stuff
which I'm not a fan of um musu was kind
of but it's such a weird [__] thing
to explain people there's so much
explain be stars to a Nory imagine me
being a m mature Utopia yeah thinking
about the same yeah imagine me being a m
kensei fan being like okay so the latest
Arc uh he gets erectile dysfunction but
actually that's a that's a deep [__]
character study that goes somewhere and
adds to his characters I swear to God I
swear to God guys I swear it was
actually hinted that in season one uh
but everyone just missed it I think more
men could help with
that help we need more representation
for men who can't get it
up I know you go to America and I swear
every second commercial is an erectile
dysfunctional like commercial it's it's
it's so weird where it's you know they
can do you have trouble getting it up
kind of like that kind of like that yes
side effects may include male
pregnancy some [__] up [__] you
know but oh yeah there is a lot of weird
sides to do do you think do you want
that weird side to disappear or do you
just want more people to accept that
that is a part of anime while also you
know acknowledging definitely the latter
I think like no matter what the west or
like anyone says normally or not you
know when they look at some of the
weirdest [__] that comes out of the
anime world like Japan's not going to
stop doing that [__] right cuz obviously
they can do whatever the [__] they want
to stand out right but I think all I
want as an as a Mong and anime fan to
just be like all right you don't have to
like this [__] but just leave it alone
yeah you know and if you want to check
it out then by all means go for it but
if you don't want to hey man that's fine
there's there's a thousand episodes of
One Piece you can go watch it's totally
cool you know yeah I I think there's
there's a different separation between
it's it's like the Shonen normal fans
discovering the rest of anime that
become a thing uh and you know I I like
to me I always mentally like separated
oh this is the stuff I meant to take
seriously and this is the stuff I'm like
ah this is just [__] weird although I
say that but I swear every year just
just there seems to be like a new title
that is kind of hinted at being like Oh
there's an anime adaptation that's
coming out of this and I read the title
I go oh I I can see why people think
anime fans are [__] weird you just
read the title of some of these shows
and it's just like yeah you know
what about the latest thing you tweeted
about yeah that like people got on my
ass my sister or
something wait what hold on I'll I'll
pull it up I'll pull it up even that the
monk category I just mentioned earlier
is like the get pregnant or get
pregnated on I I tweeted out earli this
month uh I just said titles like this
remind me why people think anime fans
are weird the title is my little sister
is the best masturbation Mater that's
the one yeah what yeah uh alternative
title my little sister is the best fap
material and I'm like okay look and I'm
like this is not a Doan why yeah this is
not a Doan and like it's getting an
anime adaptation I'm just like okay I
can see why normies think anime fans are
weird with this kind of [__] I totally
get it unless this is some kind of plot
for like euthanasia I don't see how this
could go well you know the term for like
a faty material in Japanese can be okazu
me just like something that you eat
outside dish like that's how you can eat
keep eating the rice you know main thing
sa is rice and you canot just eat rice
you want something else like you steak
or something else so okaz is something
else that would encourage you to keep
eating rice yeah that's that's the
Japanese word for fat material so it's
not like in in Japanese the title
doesn't sound too bad because it's
something that aids you in your
masturbation yeah that's literally where
the word comes from it's like you could
you could just eat white rice by itself
as in like you could just fat with just
your mind but why don't you have
something on the side that could help
you with that it works right where the
word white so it kind of
I mean I'm I didn't I didn't think that
far I never eat rice I'm just going to
think a come every time I eat
rice that's that's my favorite Japanese
word it's just it's just the whoever
came up with that word is a
genius well you learn something newaz
chat okazu so what's the
plot what do you
think so I have to explain there could
be something it could be a let's okay
you know what let's look it up can I can
we can I hear a synopsis at least it
can't be that bad right you're not be
surprised by the Emoto content because
there's Oro already right he loves Oro I
mean okay okay okay I will be that one
em like orimo Defender I'm like that
that was that was what opened up the
floodgates I think but a lot of people
watch that and forget that it was like a
cool um story about otaku culture when
back when back when an environment where
otaku stories just weren't as mainstream
as they are now we just have a hands up
who is an only child here again um hands
up I actually have a big
brother only child got that's why
can't I would just like to say when I
looked up the title of this show uh on
Google the f one of the first things
that came up was oremo episode
14 episode 14 yeah I actually I actually
can't find like a my anime list for this
show I don't think it's getting an anim
I think it's just getting a light no or
it's a light novel or a mango I couldn't
imagine writing a light novel about
jacking off to your sister yeah how
bored do you have to
be I mean if there's a market for it
it's it was like
interesting it was like very interesting
hearing Joey's interview with the reader
of heiler author where you know respect
the hustle there he was like there was
the market for it and uh he provided the
material for the market you know yeah he
just all right here we go yeah yeah but
I sudden I think the market shouldn't
exist oh true it should be more Niche I
feel like may we shouldn't have this
Market some some things I think you
should should be kept some things I
think should be kept in like the hentai
kind of category where oh my God I don't
know if I can read this synopsis bro oh
no oh no this this might have to be like
patreon how about how about M can the
selective moment okay all right M on
good luck all right I'm going to read
the synopsis bad it can't be how bad can
it be so I guess the synopsis is tall
from the perspective of the main
character is it a light novel by the way
uh yes it's a light novel it's a web
novel oh God all right this is the
synopsis verbatim Miu my own sister
catches me into my favorite sister
erotic game she's always cool
straightforward and a bit salty but for
some reason she ends up helping me no no
in what way in what way this is this is
a hentai this is this is no way this is
a it gets worse it get worse I
on my little sister's
skin and have her touch it after a lot
of skinship now I can't bust a nut
unless I'm thinking of her
damn that's a total hintai that's the
synopsis damn you know like I don't mind
please censor that I don't want that
audio on the internet I don't mind if
something like this
exists if it's just like in the hintai
category but if it was a hintai
understandable weird but understandable
but this is a web novel yeah as in there
this is a web novel so like there's no
images you know has it been explained
that they are biologically not related I
you know what I think that's the least
of their concern cuz or for the game
they had to do that right they had to be
like biologically unrelated for the game
PSP game really yes was a PSP game yeah
p a PSP like visual novel for it yeah
okay which is not good did the anime
make that distinction oh no only for the
game because the game should be more
mainstream like you Bea one out oh man
it's so good the steps so actually for
the game they actually get married and
have a kid or or two yeah in the game
they're not biologically related the
anime they don't get married um well can
I it's a spoiler spoiler but they
do they have wedding the only that can
stand in the way the Japanese government
yeah yeah they just they're just kissing
in the anime in the very end we would
have gotten away with it if this was
Alabama what the [__] was that other
thing you made me read what you made me
read one that was a Doan that was a Doan
that okay so that was like a fan that's
not canon that's not canon that's that's
the whole point I don't think the game
is Canon either right no I don't think
the game is Canon was this the or I
think it would just maybe somebody who
is older than 12 like it's a game so
anybody can yeah I guess but it's not
allowed a game it's still weird though
look at least domestic girlfriend had
tact and and plots and character
development I don't know I trust you
especially with those sunglasses on I
don't
want do not talk about next time you
talk about it you got to smoking a Cuban
cigar let me talk about why domestic
girlfriend has Ted got understand the
thing about the domestic
girlfriend